we have new economic numbers they're
pretty good
new weekly jobless claims have again hit
a new pandemic era
low the department of labor once a week
releases these numbers they released
them this morning
initial jobless claims for the week
ending april
10th meaning last week came in at
576 000 new claims
this is both lower than the 700
000 number that was expected and also
the lowest in the era of the pandemic
continuing claims uh for the week ending
april 3rd
3.7 million the uh basically right on
track with what was
expected and these are numbers that are
likely to continue improving
if we can keep vaccinating quickly we've
talked about how
in some sense the unemployment numbers
are
inversely correlated to vaccination of
course there's a whole bunch of other
factors including local hot spots and
state-by-state guidelines what's going
on in texas
is different than what's going on in the
state of washington
as as two examples but if you look at
the vaccination
dose numbers those numbers continue to
increase we're now
up to 3.3 million doses per day
in another 40 days things could be
looking quite
good it's quite plausible that by
memorial day you will see more states
drop
mask mandates i'm not advocating for or
against it i'm sort of talking about the
the perspective that i think more and
more governors are taking here
but short of of debating that
for me the lesson here there's probably
a few lessons but the best lesson here
is
the best economic policy the best way to
protect and shield
and recover the economy during a
pandemic
has always been to just deal with the
virus and what i mean by that is
early on in march debates about
flights and debates about freedom and
debates about
masks and closures quarantines and the
constitutionality of lockdowns and all
of that stuff
there has always been one path
which is the most uh the the more
quickly
you deal with the virus regardless of
the debates around freedom and
constitutionality and whatever
dealing with the virus most quickly
will help the economy and we have
examples of it new zealand did an
incredible job dealing with the virus
they didn't need long debates over
whether to open or close or max or not
they just they did it they dealt with it
and then they had long periods of
normality where much of the rest of the
world
was very far from normality israel in
terms of vaccination israel was
able to strike a deal early with pfizer
uh being a country of only nine million
people to get enough doses for everybody
uh in exchange for sharing data with
pfizer
uh businesses are open in israel
passover was almost completely normal in
israel
a couple of weeks ago the entire time
the united states wasted time with
conversations that were being forced
upon us
by the right by the trumpists by the
anti-massacres by whoever else
and all along the best medical policy
was the best economic policy that's what
we learned and it is increasingly
borne out in the data that we get had we
figured out testing earlier instead of
trump saying
we don't need this slow down testing 15
cases will go to zero if we just figured
out testing and were able
to contain it we would have had a
problem of course we would have had a
problem in a country of 330 million
people
but it wouldn't have gotten as bad as it
did the economy would have gotten better
more quickly
had we had competent leadership early
the economy would have done better
all along other good indicators uh
economically by the way retail sales
up uh about nine percent higher in march
that is uh significant a lot of it is
coming from bars and restaurants
and other uh business areas um
and then the result of all of this is
the stock market popping today
all-time highs you're not seeing joe
biden tweet endlessly about it
but the dow jones industrial average was
up more than 200 points
as of when i looked at it half an hour
ago um
hit an all-time high the s p 500 hitting
an intraday
record like forever the the forever
record was hit today
uh nasdaq up one percent of course the
economy is not the stock market
but the point is all of it together
confirms
that the better we do against the virus
that's the economic policy
it's not the debate between public
health policy
and economic policy it's all the same
the economy does better when we better
deal with the virus
we better deal with the virus when we
understand
that we don't need to think about the
virus as separate and distinct from the
economy
because it all goes hand in hand we'll
hope for continued
improvement in the numbers my belief is
and again i always make very clear i'm
not
coming up with this stuff on my own i'm
looking at the public health experts
because they are the experts
it seems as though 40 days from now
numbers will look significantly better
and hopefully as a result economic
numbers will as well
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at
fair prices which is why they have over
twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman